hi I'm chef Marcel Vigneron of Wolfe
restaurant and today I'm going to be
making my mushroom risotto this is a
recipe that's really dear to me that my
mom used to make for me all the time and
this is one of the first recipes that I
can remember making with her personally
my mom got me into cooking she was kind
of a sort of like spark that ignited my
curiosity and then it just became my
occupation I cooked all throughout high
school I started off dishwashing and
then my first trip to Europe was when I
kind of came to the realization that I
was gonna do it as a career
I like the oyster mushrooms cuz I'm just
really fond of their flavor and I mean
also they're just so cute there's lovely
little mushrooms I think you could
pretty much substitute the oyster for
any other mushroom I mean you could use
a button you could use a cremini in kind
of whatever strikes your fancy one of
the things that takes out the
intimidation factor with this particular
recipe is just using the sushi rice
I think the sushi rice is a little bit
more forgiving than like a traditional
or barrio or a Canon Rowley and then
also it speeds up the whole cooking
process which is nice
recipes are guidelines and it's
important not to be afraid to deviate
from the recipe well I mean that's how I
kind of created this recipe was I didn't
have traditional risotto rice and had
sushi rice and wanted to make risotto I
basically just stir whenever I think is
necessary and I think the stirring is
actually really important towards the
end you want to have your risotto like a
little bit maybe like more wet and it
has that nice relaxing look and approach
to it where it's like if I move it it
kind of falls into place and it's not
too stiff you kind of want to be a
little bit more wet than you think
because when you add the parmesan the
parmesan is going to absorb some of that
moisture just some helpful hints to to
demystify the art of making risotto
taste the rice along the way you know
don't forget to stir you can't stir the
pot enough you're not gonna like over
stir the risotto the risotto is you know
one of our most popular dishes and it's
just one of those things that like
everybody does but we just kind of do it
a little bit differently it's nice to do
something that's really simple and just
do it well ultimately cooking it comes
down to like ingredients in execution
and if you have really good ingredients
and follow it up with great technique
you're gonna have a sound dish no matter
how simple it is
or as classic as a risotto my mom is a
classic mom she's like very supportive
and you know it's like oh it's so good
but still gonna stay idle I don't think
you can hold a candle
oh yeah so again oh yes
[Music]
you